beat him sunday murray gets help from
others like barton and in the corner
milsamp
three in a rebound by lebron he's got a
double-double
27 points 10 rebounds ninth
double-double of the season for james
the durability
filling oh and what a pass and flying
and coming out of the rafters was
anthony davis for two and now lebron one
assist away from a triple double you
talking about the double doubles
one assist away he's already have one
triple double
early part of this season barton missing
the three
nuggets are cold the lakers have watched
their shooting percentage rezi climbed
to 57
as this game has gone on and for the
first time all night denver is below
40 at 39.8 what another
beautiful pass well timed by james that
passing
of james he's got a lot of attributes
that's about as good of one as he has
isn't it
so i i got to appreciate it but not only
that you got to appreciate the greatness
for the sustained amount of time he's
done it 18 years professionally
at the highest level
we mentioned that oh what a pass right
there martin tucker
what a pass he is houdini
[Applause]
that is just that is just amazing he led
the
league last year as we mentioned in
assists there's a foul on the perimeter
caldwell point in stride
bull bull was in i mean taylon horton
tucker in stride with the easy finish
on point pass just an amazing you
mentioned it reggie his second triple
double of the season
and he will
take a breather well look at this we
showed you this before
we really got into this one tonight with
a floater right here
which will not go
[Applause]
well you know we're talking about lebron
james and the numbers and i know we're
laying it on thick but
he had 27 points tonight he has
he has the most 25 point games in nba
history tonight was his 800th kevin
think about this 825
plus points scoring games he has scored
25 or more points in 62
[Music]
think about this 62 percent of his
career
games he has scored 25 plus points
that's greatness that is greatness
and look at the big mask they just gave
him right there it's as big as his head
we've got all kinds of new players on
the floor
although harold has it right here as he
makes a spin move on zeke
naji who is a rookie out of arizona
state